Johannes Keplar inherited his love of
wood carving from his grandfather the
materials he needs grow right at his
doorstep wood is used for everything
here heating building and art let's give
daddy a give actually targets on the
school day it's an age-old tradition -
Schwartz what's your arm it comes from
the fact that the black forest region
used to be very poor this house ought to
hear long but everyone earned a living
from farming and alongside that they had
to make shingles for their own houses
and utensils from oil went octopus
changed in North Hood in his exhibition
room
this artist displays a wide array of his
sculptures the spectrum ranges from
decorative figures to biblical subjects
to carnival masks
his first tip takes us to the opposite
side of burner Valley the large
sculpture standing here was also carved
by Kupfer it depicts a figure from a
local legend it's at the entrance to the
matthean vault adventure trail the heme
philia Demaret involved in Belmar I
recommend bow now smash and vise
it's an enchanting woodland with a
babbling brook and pristine nature is an
easy walk for young and old and there's
lots to discover out with speeds when
taking gift sculptures point the way
through the moorland a nature protection
area typical of the high Black Forest
the adventure trail is 3 kilometres long
and has surprises in store at every Bend
on the way
then it's back to burner Johannes Kepler
recommends that art lovers visit the
hunt stormer Museum in the center of the
village install ma BA Hons Toma was born
here in Brno in 1920 he was Germany's
most famous painter he's very realistic
he painted landscapes and portraits and
in his landscapes you can see how been
how has changed with his rustic subjects
and naturalistic style hunts Toma was at
odds with the prevailing artistic styles
of his times but he stubbornly went his
own way and even became a professor at
Carra Art Academy johannes kepler's last
recommendation takes us to the peaks
above Berna an hour's walk and you're at
the top and in good weather you can see
as far as Mont Blanc in the French Alps
everywhere there are Mountain guest
houses where you can stop to rest like
the crunkle back later
Virginia you go to a vehicle down the
toilet my nail it's infilling is my last
chip is the cocklebur cooter at an
elevation of 1294 meters it's the
starting point for lots of hikes for
instance to the highest mountain in the
Black Forest the Fed back it's nearby
just three kilometers away second
highest the hats organ horn is even
closer it's a bit of an effort walking
up in summer but you can easily stop
here for a rest and in the winter you
can ride up on a ski groomer and enjoy
sledding downhill three kilometers if I
kill me the like anything here simple
dishes are on the menu such as black
forest ham and bread just the thing to
keep you fortified for the rest of your
mountain hike through the Black Forest
Oh